♪♪
- Hello, and welcome,
football fans.
It is Thursday night
and welcome to mediocre
MetLife Stadium.
I am the incomparable
Adam Lefkoe
and I am representing the Eagles
on HomerCast.
I am a self-made man
that is now a champion
and I'd like to introduce you
to my subpar co-host
who got this job
because of his father.
Hey, Chris.
- Hey, thank you
loser Philadelphia announcer
who thinks a lot of himself.
But, hey, let's not forget.
I wouldn't expect anything less
from a group of fans
that throw batteries
at Santa Claus
and, gosh, have a courtroom
in the bottom of their stadium
but you're gonna bag
on our stadium.
OK, Philadelphia doesn't mean
brotherly love in this telecast.
- It doesn't.
It's about law and order
and I think that Eli's play
has been criminal thus far.
I mean, how can you defend a guy
whose pants constantly smell
like poop at the
fear of a pass rush?
Gosh, speaking of poop,
don't your fans eat it
once you guys win
once every 40 to 50 years?
Great organization.
- Speaking of eating it,
you guys have been eating Ls.
Sixteen of the last 20 times
you've played the Eagles
you lost, talking about
the history books there, pal.
- Oh, it's OK.
We don't really care.
Close the yearbook.
It's this year, and you got
one more win than us
and you're the Super Bowl
defending champions.
Heh heh heh heh heh!
- That was an interesting laugh
to do during a broadcast
but I appreciate your energy.
Keys to the game
What are you doing
for a Giants miracle win
seeing as how all of the hope
for this season is lost?
- Well, we have exciting
offensive weapons and a future
to look forward to
with Odell Beckham Jr.
and Saquon Barkley.
That's what we're
looking forward to.
You guys right now are just
a disappointing
underperforming team that thinks
Rocky's real in Philadelphia.
and Saquon Barkley.
underperforming team that thinks
Rocky's real in Philadelphia.
Sorry, Philly.
It's a made-up character.
- Rocky. OK.
I think we can agree
on one thing, though.
Screw Dallas.
- Screw Dallas.
- Yeah, screw Dallas.
F--k those guys, man.